(sighing)
Well, um, with this rare
moment of silence, um,
there is something
I'd like to share.
Um--
(gagging and coughing)
(Eliot)
Mom?
(wheezing)
(Eliot and Ilana)
Mom, are you okay?
Honey...
(Ilana)
She's choking!
She's choking-- help.
(Ilana)
She's choking.
She's choking, help!
Help, somebody, please help.
Trey, Trey, help!
(Abbi and the Wexlers
calling out)
Coming!
(Eliot)
Please, somebody.
(Arthur)
Somebody help!
Somebody!
(Ilana)
Does anybody know CPR?
(all shouting)
Here we go!
Work with me.
Hoh!
(Abbi)
Oh, my God.
(Arthur)
Jesus.
Are you okay, honey?
(Bobbi groaning)
Can you breath?
(Abbi)
Are you okay?
Oh, god damn lychee.
Oh, Jesus,
that was (bleep) scary.
(Eliot)
Sit down.
You okay?
Yeah.
(Eliot)
Take it easy.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
(sighing)
Trey?
Who the (bleep) is Trey?
(gasping)
Kirk Steele.
Abbi, how did you know
Trey was here?
Oh.
We're on a date.
Oh my God.
This is not...
Oh my God!
The condom in your room?
(scoffs)
The whole time?
The whole time!
I have to go.
I have to leave now.